Democrats know exactly what they're
doing and I wrote about this the day of
the again on ancter subs.com the day of
after the um Alvin Bragg absurd
indictment in New York Trump was dead in
the water before that nobody showed up
at his announcement speech Fox cut away
from it it was a bore he was collapsing
in the polls but the smart Democrats I
mean okay I'll admit on MSNBC they
genuinely hate him yeah time but that
dovet tales with the smart Democrats
like David Axelrod sitting back and
saying okay here's our reelection plan
for Joe Biden trick Republicans into
nominating Donald
Trump and man did Republicans fall for
it